today's Home Affairs Council focus
particularly on the implementation of
the Malta declaration the implementation
plan is about building capacity for the
Libyan Coast Guard's about improving
conditions for migrants in the center
and also helping those who wish to
return to their countries to do so
through assisted voluntary return it is
about fighting criminal gangs it's also
about taking a regional approach to
avoid routes shifting and supporting
regional cooperation there is still a
lot to be done on the location and it is
important to coordinate and see that as
much as possible is done in time there
is the need to have a more effective
return policy bearing in mind they need
to act at the eleven and in close
coordination between all the EU Turkish
statement continues to work the European
Union is and remains committed to the
full implementation of all its elements
there should be no more talk about
relocation but delivery with spring
approaching there is no time to waste
the rooster return exists for years
already but should be better implemented
in a coordinated and effective manner by
all member states the battleground to
fight terrorism is shifting increasingly
online today homegrown radicalization is
our biggest challenge this once again
demonstrates that migration and
terrorism are not related contrary to
what some political voices are saying in
you